À 4 Amber, l'image
qu'on voit de l'agricultif sur les réseaux sociaux,
est-ce que c'est 1 juste reflet de la réalité,
à votre avis,
oui, je pense, euh je pense que c'est 1 juste reflet. Euh.
Aujourd'hui,
c'est très bien qu'il y a des femmes qui se lancent euh.
À faire ça. Il faut pas avoir honte de ce qu'on est
et euh on a le droit d'être là. Donc euh
oui, bien sûr, c'est très bien.
On va s'intéresser à 1 autre
aspect de la vie d'agricultrice.
Vous avez 25 ans,
vous, euh la transmission,
c'est peut-être pas encore le
sujet que vous vous posez, euh,
le plus parce que vous n'avez pas d'enfants, je crois.
Mais est-ce que le métier d'agriculteur,
il peut être
encore attractif pour les jeunes filles aujourd'hui ?
Oui, évidemment.
Après, ce qui pose
ce qui pose problème,
c'est-ce que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure,
l'aspect financier,
euh, aujourd'hui,
il faut quand-même avoir des revenus fixes si on veut
construire quelque chose,
1 foyer, notamment 1 maison, 1 foyer,
euh, il faut quand-même avoir 1 revenu qui est sûr
en agricole, c'est-ce qui est très compliqué ?
Y a aussi l'aspect euh,
administratif.
On nous rajoute encore euh encore des tonnes de
de papiers à faire pour 1 transmission,
euh, 1 installation euh. Quelconque.
Donc c'est vrai que c'est très compliqué à gérer.
C'est pour ça que dans l'alliance rural, on propose
dans le programme
de supprimer les droits de succession,
donc qui allégera. 1 p'tit peu l'aspect financier
et après à taux 0 aussi au niveau des banques
pour les nouveaux installés.